We are a nation under God, and I believe God
intended for us to be free. We must realize
that no arsenal or no weapon in the arsenals
of the world is so formidable as the will
and moral courage of free men and women. The
price for this freedom at times has been high,
but we have never been unwilling to pay that
price. Those who say that we’re in a time when
there are no heroes, they just don’t know
where to look. The sloping hills of Arlington
National Cemetery with its row upon row of
simple white markers bearing crosses or stars of David.
Their lives ended in places called Belleau
Wood, The Argonne, Omaha Beach, Salerno, and
halfway around the world on Guadalcanal, Tarawa,
Pork Chop Hill, the Chosin Reservoir, and
in a hundred rice paddies and jungles of a
place called Vietnam. They add up to only
a tiny fraction of the price that has been
paid for our freedom.
To fallen soldiers let us sing
Where no rockets fly nor bullets wing
Our broken brothers let us bring
To the Mansions of the Lord
No more bleeding, no more fight
No prayers pleading through the night
Just divine embrace, eternal light
In the Mansions of the Lord.
Where no mothers cry and no children weep
We will stand and guard though the angels sleep
Through the ages safely keep
The Mansions of the Lord.
Ready. Aim. Fire
Ready. Present arms.